now listen there's a big development in
the war on Trump is he slowly being
Goldfinger to death by his self tanner
only time will tell
no I'm talking about a much more
insidious attack from a much more human
enemy let's jump back up to last Friday
when Trump dropped some policy genius
our top story president Trump refusing
to certify the Iranian deal because
they're not complying to the terms as
the president said I am announcing today
that we cannot and will not make this
certification
that's right certification is for
suckers a belief I hold to this day in
spite of how many lifeguard jobs
it cost me now what's wrong with this
Iran deal let me show you I got it right
here now let's see it's okay this
doesn't matter doesn't matter it doesn't
matter doesn't matter doesn't matter
doesn't matter here it is on the last
page signed Barack Obama they didn't
even try to hide it but not everyone in
Trump's cabinet agrees with this
decision to back out of the Iran deal
Iran is not in material breach of the
agreement and I do believe the agreement
to date has delayed the development of a
nuclear capability by Iran do you
believe it's in our national security
interests at the present time to remain
in the jcpoa I say yes or no question
yes senator I do I recognize that pause
that's the same pause I use when my
employees asked if we have an HR
department
so now apparently generals know more
about military matters in the president
of the United States slash one-time Miss
Universe her own her Donald Trump and
it's not just the generals turning on
Donald Trump look criticism of President
Trump it's all coming from folks who
would normally be pretty supportive of a
conventional Republican president
senator bob Corker of tennessee used the
phrase heading toward World War three
senator Ben Sasse at Nebraska recanting
on the oath you took and even the
president's close friend Tom Barrett
he's better than this
now that clip is from Meet the Press
which you know I'm skeptical of Chuck
Todd has a ponytail and I won't trust a
word out of his mouth until he turns his
head it shows it but those people did
say those things which brings me back to
the war on Trump remember remember that
enemy I was talking about
well now it's clear who Trump's biggest
enemy is friends friends of the
president criticizing his remarks
friends friends friends
they say keep your friends close and
your enemies closer
which is a credo I've always lived by
although it makes parties at my house
contentious so I have so many fondue
shaped scarves but as we all know
friends are not the closest enemy that
of course is skeletons the enemy within
trying to undermine our strongest ally
muscles okay where was I friends yes
friends who are the enemies let's call
them frenemies a word I just made up
Trump's frenemies treat him like a chump
and here's an example right here
back in July Trump's so-called friend
held a meeting to download him on
America's defenses around the world like
which countries are not and are America
stuff like that and Trump he had a great
idea in this briefing it included a
slide that had a look at the historical
US nuclear arsenal President Trump said
well you know why don't I have more why
don't we have more nuclear weapons now
and any referenced back to the higher
number which was well over 30,000
historically shortly after Rex Tillerson
called the president a moron my source
didn't just say that he called him a
moron he said an effing moron bad news I
looked into it and it turns out effing
doesn't mean friendly it means
I'm sick of this Trump has done
everything for these people he picked
them seemingly at random for positions
of great importance and now they're
calling Trump a moron then I'm calling
moron a compliment
what yeah big nasty women are the only
ones who can turn an insult into a
rallying cry if taking decisive action
makes you a moron then call me a moron
if looking an expert in the eye and
saying thanks but no thanks smart ass
makes you a moron then call me a moron
cue music
if idolizing the past and wanting to
take us back there even though everyone
says that the idyllic thing you're
trying to return to never actually
existed and that you're just a man a
more nukes based on a graph you saw with
lots of big shapes and colorful lines
makes you a moron then you better
believe I'm a moron too
what I'm saying is if Trump is a moron
then I'm Laura
and I am not alone Tim Tim is a moron
yeah Jordan my girlfriends have said the
same thing for years
yeah our head of HR is a moron you know
what we are not alone there are millions
of free thinkers like us who refuse to
obey the experts and buck their
traditionalist facts am i right yes so
look out world because America is full
of morons
[Applause]